all right so if you're not already aware
chess.com just released these new cap
Bots I guess in celebration of the new
year
and their AI felines that play chess and
there's different levels there's scaredy
cat angry cat Mr grumpers catsparov
and then there's mins
uh with a very mysterious reading of one
it says men's likes chess
but how good is she
and I'm a little bit too curious I saw
this posted on Reddit actually a few
days ago and uh I've been scratching to
play uh to play mins and see what
happens
so I think I'll just hop in let me
choose and then yeah challenge no help
of any kind random color
here we go good luck to mins
Min says meow I like chess
he he
gaze along into the abyss
what does that mean also it's playing in
English
a very sophisticated opening for a kitty
I don't know what to expect but I'm
going to play something solid
okay it's playing like Magnus
like a an English type Catalan maybe
dubov inspired let me just play my main
prep
uh nothing too dubious here
there's actually a few moves I can play
Bishop D6 or Bishop E7
I've been learning Bishop D6 recently
has an interesting uh alternative to
Mainline
it's a pretty rare variation
we'll see of men's noses
all chess players eventually crumble
under my mighty paws
what is it saying
okay C5
I think this is still some Theory
I was studying this a few months ago
in preparation for my Abu Dhabi
tournament games
um yeah there's A5 and there's B6 A5
looks nice
with A5 B5
I'm just trying to like destroy me on
the queen side
okay maybe B6 and then A5
okay
this is a typical way of trying to
chisel away light spawns
how to do this
we could trade like I could trade
on B4 and then C5 and then trade Rooks
I will say it's playing like really
really strongly
I wouldn't be surprised if if mins is
somehow cheating
using some device under her paws
but it's it's too early for accusations
I don't want to get sued
or scratched
okay take Knight C6
oh
oh that makes sense opens up the bishop
but it also gives me some
hope of eventually playing Pawn E5
okay let's play Bishop A6
a nice diagonal that's the worst piece
for black usually in the Caroline this
light squared Bishop
and that was C6
I want to play Queen CA to B7
or I just want a complete development
if I play Knight D7
[Music]
looks reasonable although 97 Knight D4
Queen A4
I already have to be careful let's play
Queen C8
idea Queen B7
mm-hmm
mins got some moves
controlling the center
massaging my dark squares
but now Knight D7 I wouldn't mind the
trade
I have to be really careful of this
battery
oh dear
don't hurt me
Rook B8
wait Rook B8
I'm usually not scared of adorable cats
but I'm scared of White's Pawn thrust
because White's already threatening this
move just squeezing me
in the center if I take
that's probably no good
okay what if I just play Rook B8
this Pawn is backwards if this all play
98 and be a little bit sad
okay here I can take
wow
so wants to put the nylon B6
mins has been oddly silent for the last
few moves
which is maybe a good sign
but maybe not
okay I need a plan
or maybe I just need to like hunker down
Bishop f8
ensuring my Queen's not tied down now my
Knight's no longer pinned
rookie five okay
Bishop B5
honestly it's playing like some
robot creature
this is really terrifying
like it's trying to dominate me on all
areas of the board
the thing is I'm still holding on like
I'm not too dead just yet
uh Queen A2
the problem is white has every single
thing defended
like the queen defends a bishop also
defends upon
like where is White's weakness
I have to find a large dog to help me
out
okay that's a good sign
retreating but what do I do next
night
maybe like H5 Knight G4
and there's also rookie eight
play rookie Gates and just trade
and then later maneuver the Knight
the problem is I want to play rookie I
just don't see what to do after Knight
t7
thank you
um
okay I have another plan queen A7
and then Knight D7 just to trade Knights
korsman stops my idea
what is this
I play rookie eight
okay we trade
I saw that but I'm I'm still defending
kind of
but what do I do Bishop E7
there should be seven there's like Queen
E5 man
what is this
we need five maybe I move back
let's try this
I want to provoke some trades
yeah so if takes I take here
oh dear
I got tricked
I feel like I'm getting squeezed
Bishop
I have to play Bishop d8 like what else
to do
don't hurt me
foreign
oh no
what is this
it just brattled off like a forced
mating sequence I don't think I could
have stopped it
what is this
I'm just dead
or am I
wow so Queen h8 would have been met with
King G6
now is there any hope please don't see
your Bishop
dough
oh no my queen
your queen is gone
okay where's my stalemate trick
you can have my Pawns
ah
oh no
okay mins is not to be messed with
one more game
okay this time I know what I'm up
against rematch I'm white this time
let's play a London
I feel like minton's just played like
Magnus Carlson or even stronger maybe
just like stockfish
okay
I'm gonna be ultra solid this game no
more messing around
no more Mercy
this is a main line of London this is
already a good line for white
no mercy here
B3 coming
[Music]
um
what does this move
don't remember that being a move
I mean there's Bishop G5 I think I'll
play Bishop E5 first
eventually I'm gonna play B3
[Music]
ooh fancy move
that's a very logical move
how do I not lose a pawn
I think Queen C2
A3 Knight A3 it's a little bit sad
I want to play E4
E4 achieved
I even realized I I could have um
no I can't win the pong because B2 hangs
um
p92
okay the idea was to play B4
I think I'll go for it
B4 takes takes
what is this move
that's a free night
what is it doing
it just sacked a night for seemingly
nothing
foreign
there's no way this works for black
although
this Pawn is a little bit tender
if I'm up a piece
might be five
yeah I lose a pawn
oh I lose that pawn
still be okay though
um
maybe two
don't hurt me
if I play Rook
Rook takes B4
how do I get out of this in Rook D2
I'm still up a piece but it has still
all eight Pawns
I completely forgot about that move too
I have this move no
Maybe
Maybe
my first capturing of a pawn
okay let's take
Bishop E2
I'm still alive kind of sort of
what is this
Rook C8
what is this
Queen D1 I guess I'm up a whole Rook
here
for three Pawns
oh no
Rook C1
ah oh no my queen
my queen is gone okay
never resign when you have a broken
Bishop
I can't even Castle here
I still do I still have casting rights
there's only one plan here so trick it
into stalemating me
play B6 first
or to trick it into like some funny
checkmate
back rank mates
stop it
stop it
it has so many queens
dough
I feel so broken